testing
good morning everybody
i'd like to convene the committee of
conference on house bill 624.
you will note that there are three house
members and three senate members in
attendance the fourth house member
representative notter
apparently confused the dates
in her mind and is currently on her way
to vermont
so she will not be joining us i think
she agreed already
i'm kidding for this committee of
conference
so let's get started
the
house obviously non-concurred with the
[Music]
amendment
drafted by the senate
and we are here this morning to
to ask
the senate to remove
section 5 of its amendment
the section that
specifically refers to
net energy metering hydroelectric
generators
rsa
362-a colon 9.
section 20.
the reason we're asking the senate to
remove that section
is that two house committees heard
house bill
624. and
two separate committees s t and e and
ways and means
and the house then passed hb 624 twice
but no house committee heard the senate
amendment
specifically the section 5 that i
referred to a minute ago
and the house never had a chance to
pass that bill
or even vote on the bill one way or the
other
and we believe that there are many
questions that remain unasked and
unanswered
about
the section five in the amendment
questions that the house never got a
chance to ask for example
how much will it cost
will brookfield cease operations without
this change
is it possible brookfield could make
other arrangements
what compelling need exists for this
legislation
why was this amendment offered at the
last minute
and there are other questions as well
there's some senate language that was
added about energy storage for example
and representative herron has some
questions about that
there's a further wrinkle here too and
that is that the house
can't
cannot
consider legislation legislation that
impacts costs without
first hearing that legislation in the
house
and i know there's disagreement about
whether net metering shifts costs or not
but if it does that could impact state
and municipal budgets
and it
a consideration like that would prevent
the
house from even
considering
section 5 of the amendment
so as a result of all this the house
believes that
the section 5 of the amendment if that
was deleted we could move forward with
this bill
and that is the house position at this
point
so i would like to hear from the senate
your reaction to our
request
well um
senator yeah i'll say a couple words
thank you uh
rose um
as we discussed earlier i understand the
position and the issues of the house on
this whole matter and also matters of
process and i just thought i'd offer a
couple of thoughts
it was our feeling that
what we went through on 315 and 91 last
year
that we certainly
were attempting to make sure that the
the increase in the cap
would be applicable where it
appropriately could be and that here you
know i call what you want a glitch or a
kind of a
just a a methodology of how the wiring
how the transmission is done so you've
got two facilities
that are using the same
transmission but they are separate
facilities and so the problem is then
they get counted as one and they they go
over the cap so i and that to me seemed
like kind of a technical change that we
you know the intent and what we worked
on 315 and 91
dealt with so in terms of the house not
hearing this particular thing well in a
way you know it felt it did last year
now
two other things on
the cost shift potential
it does seem to me that the directions
that were given to the puc last year to
look into the cost shifting issue
um and that you know we had the
committee and then the direction to the
pec to kind of look into that more
generally which i don't know what now is
91 or 315 we put that in but that that
work is underway and i would assume that
would include
um
this as well
in terms of the questions that are asked
again looking back to
the process we did on i guess it was 315
um
where the decision was made to ask those
questions towards
the poc and that's what we did the last
time could do it here it seems to me for
one the ones that you enumerated um and
and i think also
that um
the kind of questions about uh
you know the costs and so on that it
i mean i like cooking cans down the road
more than anybody else does but that's
why we're here most of the time isn't it
um you know that it seemed to me to be
possible if you want those questions
asked to put in a
time period under which this arrangement
is good i mean give it a couple years
and that way the questions could be
answered either through the existing puc
or some more language added to this
that would do that so that those are
kind of
my thoughts of you know why we ended up
at our position aside from saying that
this is you know the the issue of these
plants is very important to the senate
and that's been the case for a long time
thank you senator
uh could you
one of you refresh my memory from this
public hearing that we had in the senate
on the
section five portion of the amendment
what was the answer to the question of
why this amendment was offered so late
in the process do any of you remember
that
uh i don't remember that being worded
that way white was being authored so
late i do recall you um
agreeing to it
and then we asked you to come to the mic
because we didn't record it and then
you said i agree
with the mic
that is true i did agree that
it seemed like a reasonable proposal
and then when we had discussions in the
house about it
all these questions arose that
none of us could answer
and so that altered our thinking about
this proposal
i still don't understand why waiting to
introduce new legislation next fall
would
have a
significant impact on
this going forward
a few months delay doesn't seem like a
lot to me
that's if we all get elected
and
institutional knowledge leaves with with
individuals if they do not come back
you have to start the conversation all
over again this isn't exactly uh
fun stuff to do it's not something that
you retain it's something that that
comes along with the institution of
individuals who have been working on
this for years
we thought we had an agreement last year
we fixed some things we just needed to
torque it that's all we were trying to
do
and
um there is an amendment
that i forwarded to i don't know if you
if you want i mean
it's lengthy but if you uh
if you take time to look at it
i think it addresses some of the issues
that you you're concerned with but
it seems as though you know um
we're trying to solve something here
and you can raise a thousand questions
in in torpedo something which i think is
you know uh
you know
that's what's happening
is this amendment something
newly created
yeah
oh so this is not the amendment that was
passed by the senate oh okay
let me take a look at it
maybe while we're doing that i have also
have a couple of questions that maybe
can be looked at it appears what this is
saying is it applies to
um hydro facilities who were operational
before july 1st 2021
i guess the first thing i'd like to know
is how many of those are there how much
what are we talking about here two 150
or is it just a special interest bill
for one particular company second that
provision of july first 2021 doesn't
seem to apply to energy energy storage
facilities so
the way i read this is that whatever how
many of these places existed they could
go in and put in 10 15 energy storage
facilities as long as they were all less
than one megawatt and then they could be
dispatched whenever at the rate of 15 20
megawatts if there was many that many of
them there
at one time
so again it seems like energy storage
facilities aren't covered by this 925
line 25 line twenty five okay
nothing expectation shall be deemed to
approve or allow or participate in
energy storage facilities in energy
metering unless otherwise approved or
allowed by law
then what's the point of having if it's
that's if it sounds like to me the law
already approves it right up there where
it says energy storage facilities so now
you're saying if the law doesn't say it
then they're not deemed to be approved
but
listed in line seven they certainly are
approved because they're listed right
there you can't have it both ways the
other question i have is how are these
uh
items dispatched by iso if you get
accumulation of i don't know six ten
fifteen megawatts being uh put on the
grid at one time how does iso treat them
do they treat them as a generator
uh because they're over five megawatts
and they have leadering concerns that
have to be addressed and so forth are
they treated like net metering as six
individual or ten individual
one megawatt facilities they answer your
first question there's only a couple of
hydros that that we're addressing here
and
we know that so i'm not gonna play games
here
um i think you're trying to kill the
bill specifically
if i if i may miss you um
go ahead
go ahead now um
in terms of your question about the incl
the what the amendment does the first
part in the second part um the inclusion
of energy storage facilities
up above
says they're eligible
for the net metering but down below
it says well yes they're eligible but
they can't it can't happen unless
there's an approval the approval process
so i think it needs to be up top so that
they're listed as eligible but the
procedure as to whether or not it's done
is down is down below sorry i'm a little
confused senator on that one because it
seems to be saying they're eligible but
then and less deemed approved right or
allowed the participation in net media
during unless otherwise approved or
allowed by law what this is a law that
allows them or an order or decision
issued or ruled adopted by the
department of energy or the public
utilities commission so it sounds as if
they're already allowed by law and now
you're saying we have to have an
additional law to do it or the puc or
doe has to come in and approve it i
guess that
uh the difference is that the word
eligible doesn't mean approved
i
well that's part of the reason i don't
like medvilles like this they don't have
time to bet because i'm still not sure
what it says and also does anybody know
how they're dispatched from the by the
iso
no my question is this is characteristic
of the kind of questions that remain
unanswered
and
give the house
serious concerns about whether we should
move forward at this time
we feel that it would be appropriate to
bring this bill forward in the fall
or next session so that the full house
can have a chance to
weigh in on these issues ask these
questions get these answers
and make a determination about whether
or not this is good policy to move
forward with
well i may if i may make one more
comment on that um it was asked earlier
about the timeliness and i think in the
hearing report on pages five and six
some of that gets addressed and that
they then we passed 91
and they merely went about their
business working with eversource
uh to implement and they discovered that
there were some issues
that
the legislation needed to clear up so
that process had to stop
so that's that's why this fix here
let's what we had thought the intent of
91 would be to go forward
um now and and uh mr chairman i
i you know here it is it's what is it
may whatever and um
uh you know we have the opportunity to
walk away with the opportunity to try to
do something and um
it just it does seem to me that it would
be possible to put in here
that this
shall be effective until a certain date
and that lets lets them get going and
get the negotiations finished
and then um
you know it uh
then we'd have a chance to take as many
more bites at the apples we want next
time and some of those questions would
likely be answered in the proceedings at
the puc and elsewhere over it so
it could you know we could say that um a
repeal date on that paragraph of what do
you want you know 2024 july 1st 2024
something like that it gets this gives
us two years of the session to
do what we want to do
and then that's that would be a way to
not have the whole building just die
so you're suggesting then that
under six effective date
we change
the language to indicate that section
five
would take
effect on
on passage but then it would repeal
it would sunset
two years after
and that way they could do what they got
to do
um make the case that if the case needs
to be made there will be probably some
poc
we'll get a report about the cost
shifting from the puc we'll this
some of these dockets might come forward
to prove
this power and um i think we ought to
we're gonna need to talk to heidi take a
little recess just to chat with her
about what i'm proposing because maybe
i'm done proposing something it's just
gonna make her pull out her hair but uh
um it would be a way to get us through
today and
i know you care about the first part of
the bill
okay thank you so
it is now 10 20. let's take a break
until 10 30.
and then we'll reconvene thank you
you
okay everyone thank you very much we're
going to resume this committee of
conference after
a lengthy break and some lengthy
discussions about the issues involved
and senator waters i want to thank you
for your compromise suggestion of adding
a two-year sunset provision to this
legislation
however it doesn't seem that that would
really buy much for this legislation
and as we went through the
discussion
and the litany of questions that we have
we still don't feel comfortable
with moving forward with this
legislation at this time so
our position is going to be the same as
it was
at the beginning of this uh
at this committee of conference if we
can't
uh persuade you gentlemen to
walk away from section five then i guess
we're all gonna walk away
okay thank you very much everybody
committee of conference is adjourned
you